hi I'm Sandy I'm the lead engineer on
the open source dagster project and I
work at Elemental which is the company
that builds dagster and dagster Cloud
I'm here to talk to you today about data
Pipelines so if you're a data engineer a
data scientist a machine learning
engineer
Etc there's a good chance that one of
the main things you spend your time on
is building and maintaining data
Pipelines
what is a data pipeline
so first of all a data pipeline normally
culminates in a set of data assets a
data asset is a file a machine learning
model a table any persistent object that
captures some understanding of the world
the point of building a data pipeline is
usually to get a set of data assets that
can be used to help make a business
decision or power an application
to get to those assets you're normally
going to need to run some computations
so pull in data from external systems
transform it do machine learning and you
name it
those computations are usually going to
consume and produce other data assets
so those other data assets might be a
source data or they might capture some
intermediate stage of the data
transformation process
intermediate assets are often reusable
across a bunch of different analyzes or
applications and they're also often what
we inspect we want to debug our data
pipeline
as time passes and your team gets bigger
and you build more and more data assets
it's often useful to think about your
data pipelines in terms of an
organization organization wide graph of
data assets
it's kind of like a big supply chain
data sources are the raw materials which
get used by Downstream nodes that turn
them into more valuable products which
finally get consumed by end users
and just like Copper from a copper mine
might get used both to Mint pennies and
to build Electronics a single data
source can power dozens of data products
a single data product can also consume
data from dozens of different sources so
it often doesn't make sense to chop this
supply chain up into a bunch of discrete
flows
we'll talk more about that a little bit
later
if you've built data pipelines before
you've probably at least heard of Apache
airflow airflow is a workflow engine
meaning it's a system that takes
responsibility for executing a set of
tasks in the right order
it was the first python-based workflow
engine that had a full web interface and
this gave it a lot of popularity it's
now probably the most commonly used tool
for executing data Pipelines
but first does not always mean best
airflow is designed in a way that I
believe makes it not actually a great
fit for this task of building and
maintaining data Pipelines
the main reason is that it takes a very
narrow view of data Pipelines so it
schedules tasks but it doesn't
understand that tasks are built to
produce and maintain data assets
and it focuses on discrete isolated
workflows it doesn't model the fact that
data pipelines typically represent a
single organization-wide graph of data
assets
dagster is an organizator that takes a
broader view it was designed to assist
with the holistic task of developing
pipelines of data assets and evolving
those pipelines over time
we believe uh that taking this broader
view can make data teams dramatically
more productive and make data pipelines
dramatically more reliable
so far this is all pretty abstract and
so I'm going to spend the rest of this
talk trying to be more specific about
what I mean here
I'm going to show what it looks like to
write a data pipeline using dagster
and then I'm going to show up monitoring
and scheduling look like when you think
about your pipeline as a graph of data
assets instead of a workflow
so the most common way to build a data
pipeline in dagster is to define a graph
of data assets that you want to exist
here's a basic example with three assets
that uses dagster's python apis
I don't expect you to read the
implementations of these functions the
main piece to pay attention to is the
function signatures
so each of these decorated functions
defines a data asset that we want to
exist and as part of our data pipeline
up here at the top we've got a data
asset that's called country stats which
is a table of statistics on different
countries around the world Based on data
that's pulled from Wikipedia
by default it's going to correspond to a
pickle file on local disk which is named
country stats but you can make it
correspond to a table in S3 an ephemeral
object in memory whatever you want
the code inside the function is what we
run we want to materialize the asset by
materialize I mean compute its contents
and write them to storage
there's some fancy stuff that's going on
here with separating business logic code
from i o code the functions are
returning data frames you might have
noticed and some other code is writing
those data frames after the file system
doesn't require you to program in that
pure functional way
you can also handle the i o inside your
function but Dexter makes it easy to do
so when you want to
so the second asset here is a regression
model that's fit on the data inside
country stats
the decorated function has an argument
here which is called country stats um
that tells Dexter that it depends on
this country's stats asset and that
dependency is represented visually on
the right
last of all we've got a third asset that
depends on both of the assets that we
just covered
here's another graph of data Assets in
this case tables in Snowflake and it
loads some data on orders and users from
an application database derives cleaner
aggregated tables from those application
database tables and then uses those to
forecast future orders
what's interesting about this graph uh
is that part of it is constructed in a
slightly different way than the one that
we saw on the last slide
instead of defining assets directly in
Python we Define them inside of a DBT
project and loaded them from there
if you're not familiar with it DBT is a
framework that lets you define Tables by
writing SQL files which each contain a
select statement
the explosive model DBT as a black box
instead it represents each DBT model as
an asset in its graph
it's worth comparing the DBT section to
how this would get represented in a
workflow engine like airflow the focus
is only on tasks
because Dexter focuses on data assets it
builds this granular understanding of
the DBT dag at the level of the
individual models that each correspond
to a data asset
um as a consequence if there's a failure
in the middle of running the DPT dag you
can fix just that DBT model and then
pick up where you left off
you can tell dagster to materialize a
particular DBT model and all of the
assets that that model depends on and
it's not going to go and Trigger
unrelated tasks
in airflow you've just got a single box
because you're typically running a
single command
um to invoke DBT and that means you
execute the entire DBT dag as a single
unit you only have a course
understanding of how it relates to the
other Assets in your pipeline
DBT is just one example of a tool that
dagster plays this way with a lot of
other modern data stack tools such as
Airbus or 5trend let you Define assets
that you want to exist and dexor can
load from those tools as well
last of all there are some situations
where you just need to execute some
computations in the right order you
don't want to think about data assets
and in those cases You Can Shed this
entire asset way of looking at the world
and use dagster's underlying
computational abstractions which are
called ops and jobs
if you're familiar with airflow there
are rough analogs of tasks and Dags
I'm not going to get into the details of
how that works right now but the point
of this slide is just that Dexter
doesn't force you to think in assets
they're available when you need them and
if you're migrating code over from a
task-based workflow engine you don't
need to shift your entire mental model
to get stuff working
but back to Dexter's asset apis because
that's the focus of this talk
um as we've written code to define a set
of assets we can launch a web server
that points to that code in the most
simple setup we just have to CD into the
directory where that code lives and type
dag it no processes related to actually
interview running on our laptop before
doing this it's very lightweight
um and a quick reminder that everything
I've shown you up to this point um and
for the rest of this talk is open source
so after running dag it we get the
visual representation of our data
pipeline that we saw earlier
at this point it's just a set of tables
that we expect to exist but none are
actually materialized in Snowflake yet
we can remedy that by clicking this
materialize all button on the upper
right and that's going to launch a run
that materializes the Assets in the
right order
if we click one of the assets we can
look at the metadata that was recorded
as part of this materialization
so materialization isn't just a record
saying that a competition ran it's also
a description of the object that was
produced by that computation
for example here we chose to record the
parameters and mean squared error of our
forecasting model
once we've deployed our pipeline to
production we want to be able to
understand and communicate what it's
doing and we want to be able to find out
if there are problems and fix them
this is an error area where the focus on
assets really shines
if there's a problem in production we're
often going to learn about it because
someone tried to use a data asset and
that asset doesn't look like they
expected it to
um many of the common questions we have
when operating and monitoring our data
pipelines involve assets so we want to
know whether an asset is up to date what
needs to be run to refresh the asset
um when the asset is going to be updated
next what code and data we're actually
used to generate the asset
Dexter hosts a page for each data asset
and anyone who cares about an asset can
find it and learn about it so here's the
page for the order predictions table
that we looked at earlier
in addition to information about the
last time that we materialized the table
this page also includes metadata that
we've recorded like how many rows it has
evaluation for the model metrics for the
model Etc
if we think it has stale data we can see
the most recent time that it was updated
and if it's out of date we can hit this
material as materialize button to
um uh
uh to refresh it immediately
often an asset's problems stem from
assets that it depends on which are
further up in the graph
so from the page that we were just on we
can go to the lineage Tab and see all
the assets that this asset depends on
unlike with a workflow engine this
lineage is based on data dependencies
not execution dependencies
that means that even if the predicted
orders table doesn't get refreshed on
the same schedule as the users table we
can still trace the lineage between them
so this lets us go very deep to find
problems
and it's not just about tracing lineage
even if the predicted orders table and
the users table are upgraded updated at
different cadences we can kick off an ad
hoc run that includes both of them so
for example if it's really important
that predictive orders gets the most
up-to-date data we could kick off a run
that materializes it and all of its
dependencies at once
foreign
manually materializing assets is useful
especially when we're developing but uh
we can't stop there
um we can't stop there because assets
are constantly changing
new Upstream data is constantly arriving
and we're constantly changing the code
that derives our assets from that
Upstream data
the result is that our asset
materialization is naturally Drift from
their definitions over time
where that drift occurs we need to
launch computations to bring those
materializations in line with their
definitions
and launching computations is typically
the job of an orchestrator
we shift our perspective to think about
scheduling and orchestration from the
perspective of data assets it starts to
look a little bit different
managing change in data assets boils
down to a few basic elements
uh first of all to compute our data
assets we typically run code
when that code changes we eventually
want to update our data assets to
reflect the New Logic
we derive our data assets from Upstream
data so our code executes on Upstream
data to produce our data assets and when
that Upstream data changes or grows we
eventually want to update our assets to
incorporate those
last of all depending on how our data
assets are used we'll have different
requirements for how up-to-date they
need to be
if we're able to express our intentions
to the orchestra directly in these terms
then the orchestrator can do a really
faithful job at scheduling
materializations at the time I need them
and avoid doing unnecessary work when we
don't need it to
but most orchestration tools don't
actually think in these terms
um they require thinking and imperative
workflows sequences of tasks that run
together on fixed schedules
this imperative workflow model has some
big frictions
so for one it makes it hard to express
what should happen in some common
situations
for example let's say we've got two
tables that depend on the same Upstream
table
for one of these tables we wanted to
incorporate events within an hour of
when they occur
for the other one it's more expensive to
compute and we only care about it being
up to date daily
if we want to schedule this pretty basic
graph with workflows it gets pretty
awkward fast
so one option would be to try to do it
with two overlapping workflows um one
that we schedule hourly and one that we
schedule daily
but sometimes these workflows will run
at the same time and will redundantly
update that Upstream table twice when we
only need to do it once
or alternatively we could have an hourly
workflow that includes the fact table
and then a daily workflow that does it
um but if we want to do this then we
might need to find a way to make sure
that the daily workflow waits for part
of the hourly workflow to complete
otherwise it might get stuck with yes or
ways yesterday's data so we end up
needing to have some sort of fancy
conditional logic that Bridges between
these different workflows
um third we could try putting them all
together into one big workflow in that
case we would need some special
conditional logic within our workflow to
make sure that the daily table only runs
some of the time
um among other reasons this is weird
because now our orchestrator can't
actually tell us that the daily table is
daily um it's part of this hourly
workflow and we get a bunch of empty
boxes for when it didn't run
as a quick side note I've personally
tried all of these approaches at
different times
um and they have their pros and cons but
ultimately I think they're all pretty
unsatisfying
uh that's just one of the patterns that
are awkward to express
um you've got other ones like this where
a daily table depends on an hourly table
I'm not going to go into the different
ways to handle this one with workflows
but I hope you get to the point I hope
you get the point um on the difficulties
of expressing these
a second related friction with
imperative workflow based orchestration
is that every time you add an asset you
have to find a dag to put it in to get
it scheduled
uh this means you have to worry about
whether daggers are getting too large
and unwieldy on one extreme or too small
and fragmented on the other
and then last of all um you get alerted
when your task fails not when your data
is out of date which is often what you
actually care about
if the system can retry and self-correct
before the deadline then nobody needs to
get paged
so how does this look different when you
think about scheduling from the asset
perspective
well in dagster you can schedule assets
to be materialized using workflows like
other tools allow but you can
alternatively uh use this option called
freshness policies
the idea behind freshness policy is that
you don't think in workflows at all and
that you instead directly specify how
up-to-date you expect each of your
assets to be
then dagster would use those policies as
constraints to determine when asset
materializations need to be scheduled
here's what the code looks like so we've
got the two aggregation assets that both
depend on the same fact table just like
we saw in the diagrams before
the first one has a freshman's policy
that says it should never be more than
an hour out of date
and the second one has a freshman's
policy that says it should never be more
than a day out of date
Dexter will automatically schedule
materializations of our assets so that
they meet their freshness policies
it'll avoid duplicating work when two
assets depend on the same Upstream asset
so it knows that the same
materialization of the fact table can be
used to help both of these Downstream
assets meet their freshness policies
and then of course these freshness
policies are represented when we're
viewing our asset
um indexers web UI so we can understand
um
uh what they're supposed to what they're
supposed to be doing
um and whether when they're violating
their slas
so that was freshness policies uh
jumping back to this slide from before
we talked about this guy on the top uh
right
if our code always stays the same and
our Upstream data is changing constantly
then thinking in terms of freshness
policies is enough
but if we sometimes change our code
or if our Upstream data isn't changing
constantly then we have the opportunity
to go even a little further to keep our
assets up to date in a principled and
organized way
we Face a couple of challenges new
situations
one is that we forget to update assets
that are stale so maybe we push a change
to our code that generates a table or a
machine learning model but we forget to
actually run that code and update it and
all of its Downstream assets so our
assets end up stale
uh or conversely we run our code too
often and that code ends up just
overriding our assets with the exact uh
same contents this is wasteful of time
and resources
ideally we would have a reliable way of
tracking which assets are stale
um
um we would only spend resources
updating those stale assets
when we say an asset is stale we mean
that it's code or its Upstream data has
changed
so dagster offers a way to handle this
through a granular asset versioning
system
the idea is that users assign
fine-grained versions to code and to
Upstream data and Dexter then uses them
to determine which assets are stale and
thus might need to be re-materialized
foreign so to demonstrate how this works
here's a small graph of software-defined
assets
it starts with some data on common
breakfast cereals and then transforms
that data to derives some insights
each of these software-defined assets
has been given a code version and that
code version represents the version of
the function that computes the asset
the contract is that as long as the
function Returns the same outputs when
provided the same inputs its version can
stay the same
so now imagine we'd like to make a
change to the code that represents this
Nabisco serials asset at the top
maybe we're fixing a bug that's causing
it to be missing some records
uh we change our code
and then we bump the corresponding
version to indicate that the code has
changed
when this new code gets deployed Dexter
can tell us that some of our assets are
now stale
the asset that we bumped the version on
is Mark stale and any assets Downstream
are also marked stale because their
contents would also change if they were
re-materialized
we can remedy the fact that these are
stale by kicking off a run that
materializes just these stale assets
changing code isn't the only way the
assets can become stale um Source data
can also change so if we use dags that
are Source assets to represent Upstream
data that our pipeline depends on we can
then use versions to track when that
Upstream data changes
here is a source asset that corresponds
to a file on our file system and we've
versioned this Source asset by writing a
observation function which looks at the
file and returns a value representing
its version
in this case we look at the last
modified timestamp of the file and use
that last modified timestamp as the
version
alternatively we could have taken a hash
of the contents of the file if it's
small enough and use that as the version
um Dexter can then call this function to
determine whether our source assets
version has changed and if it has then
Downstream assets are considered stale
so that's what I have for you today I
want to sum up everything that we talked
about here
First Data pipelines are graphs of data
assets like files tables and machine
learning and machine learning models
connected by computations
workflows are not an adequate metaphor
for data pipelines because workflows
focus on tasks not data assets and
because breaking up a data supply chain
into isolated dags is awkward and
unrealistic
Dexter was designed directly for
orchestrating data Pipelines it focuses
on keeping data assets up to date not
just on workflows of tasks
um it has freshness policies which let
you schedule without carving your asset
graph into workflows and while thinking
more directly about the requirements you
have for your data assets being up to
date
and granular versioning lets you execute
only what has changed
thank you so much for listening uh you
can check us out on GitHub which I think
you can get to with a link in the chat
or just by Googling dagster GitHub and
we'd love to see you in our slack if you
have any questions um or just want to
chat I wish you can get to it from our
website taxpayer.io
thank you